Wow that last lesson got pretty deep.
Now the kind of connection that you've
seen in Netcat is a TCP Session
which let's two programs send strings of
bytes back and forth over the network.
TCP is kind of the middle layer of
a stack of networking protocols or
protocol stack which supports all sorts
of different internet applications.
HTTP and other applications
are built on top of TCP.
And TCP is built on top of IP,
the Internet Protocol.
In this lesson, we'll take a closer
look at how these layers work together.
As we do, keep an eye out for
two things,
how each layer depends on behavior or
guarantees made by the layer below.
And also how it hides
the details of the lower layer,
giving programmers a simpler interface.